une population plus local plus
yvelinoise après deux mois d'été l'heure
est au bilan le tourisme notent une
amélioration par rapport à 2020 environ
20% pour l'hôtellerie notamment selon le
département sur l'international on est
plutôt sur la hollande la belgique
l'allemagne mais c'est vrai que les
grands touristes qui viennent par
exemple à paris qui ensuite se déverse
sur notre département cette année
n'était pas là donc au niveau de
l'hôtellerie c'est un vrai sujet plus de
dix mille visiteurs de moins du côté de
france miniature sur le mois de juillet
si les trois premières semaines de
vacances était conforme aux attentes des
équipes les trois suivantes ont vu
l'instauration du passé ni terre le 21
juillet freiné la venue du public ou aux
visiteurs pour des familles avec enfants
et tous n'étaient pas encore dans un
schéma vaccinal complet donc la première
partie en tout cas compter du 20 points
juillet a été elle plus difficile et ça
pendant quinze jours trois semaines le
temps que que le parcours actuel soit
complet et apprenaient revenue sur la
dernière partie de l'été des chiffres en
deux ça aussi pour lille de loisirs de
saint quentin en yvelines la
fréquentation a baissé de 25% en juillet
et de 20 % en août c'est vraiment la
météo qui est le facteur prédominant au
niveau des activités qu'on plus souffert
notamment tout ce qui est activités du
père promenade donc les vélos
quoi karting électrique
rosalie les manèges la buvette là c'est
typiquement familial on y vient sans
réservation et en dix ans lorsque
lorsqu'on se réveille et ben voilà le
soleil est là et là le soleil n'était
pas là donc l on cible vraiment de plein
fouet ces problèmes météo en 2020 l'été
avait été synonyme d'une baisse de
fréquentation de 70% pour les différents
sites touristiques yvelinois 2021 serait
légèrement meilleure plus d'un tiers des
professionnels estimerait que la
fréquentation est en hausse